- Le directeur général de l'OMS
a tranché : la variole simienne
est désormais une urgence
de santé publique à portée
internationale, une maladie
grave qui garde encore
tous ses mttères.
- We have an outbreak.
- L'épidémie s'est propagée
rapidement dans le monde entier
par de nouveaux modes de
transmission dont l'OMS
ne sait pas grand-chose.
Plus de 16 000 cas ont été
répertoriés dans 75 pays,faisan.
L'épicentre de la maladie
se situe en Europe.
Une étude récente parue dans le
New England Journal of Medicin
nous apprend que 98 %
des malades sont homosexuels ou
bisexuels et que la transmission
sexuelle a été soupçonnée dans
95 % des cas.
Le Dr Réjean Thomas y a
collaboré de par sa pratique
quotidienne, il appelle
à l'action.
Dr RÉJEAN THOMAS, pdg fondateur
Clinique médicale l'Actuel
- C'est quand même une maladie
qui n'est pas bénigne tant que
ça, contrairement à ce qu'on a
dit au début, et il faut essayer
de stopper cette épidémie-là
le plus rapidement possible.
- La vaccination demeure
le meilleur moyen de freiner
la propagation.
- On est chanceux d'avoir
unun vaccin, mais en même temps,
le nombre de vaccins est limité.
Pour le moment, on vaccine
les personnes une seule fois.
On a peu d'études sur
l'efficacité de ces vaccins-là
et j'espère que le Comité
d'd'immunisation du Québec
va revoir sa politique
parce qu'il ne recommande pas
de vacciner les personnes
qui travaillent ou qui font
le dépistage des patients avec
la variole simienne, alors que
les infirmiers, les infirmières
sont quand même inquiets.
- Un appel à l'action face
à la multiplication des cas
au Canada qui compte
681 infections, dont près
de la moitié au Québec.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréa